this young boy
he's 10 years old and his pervert mother
calls him the youngest transgender model
in the world and he goes by the name
noella i don't know what his real name
is so
the father of this boy has just come out
and and said a really heartbreaking
thing he said i have no say
in this child's life
so noella
whatever his real name is has a younger
brother named levi they were born to d
mccord
and timothy mccord
and then dee and timothy divorced
and dee
uh i guess became a lesbian or something
but now d and d is lesbian partner they
don't they identify as not women or as
men or i don't know they're obviously
very confused people and they're forcing
their sexual confusion and perversions
on this poor little kid and now they're
convincing the little kid to be a girl
and to strut around for other perverts
on the on the
on the red carpet
and this poor father has no say in in
his life he says i have no say in it
she's not my kid anymore this is really
interesting that even the father here is
buying into this transgender thing
but he's saying i don't i'll use the she
and i'm trying but i don't
but i just want to have some maybe not
he shouldn't be modeling or she
shouldn't be modeling or whatever
now
it's very difficult to know what
happened in this breakup
the the woman is alleging some kind of
abuse but again this woman is a complete
lunatic so i don't believe a word that
she says
and
what the father says is i was given the
opportunity to step back and let dee's
partner adopt the kids and i did that in
the hopes that they would not have all
the stress that this is causing in their
lives but obviously it's causing a whole
lot more stress because of these people
now raising this poor kid the issue here
is not men's rights or fathers rights
the issue is not even transgenderism
that's a kind of symptom of this the
issue is
divorce the fact that a divorce could
happen
is the cause of all of these problems
the fact that we have a no fault divorce
culture here
and have for 50 years although in new
york they didn't have no fault divorce
on the books until about 10 or 13 years
ago
but that's what's causing this the
problems run so much deeper they've been
building for so long
and now we see the extreme expression of
it in a 10 year old strutting down in
stiletto heels you know for twerking
around for perverts
but
the the the
earliest
manifestation of this began in the 1960s
and the 1970s and some people still
haven't woken up out of the age of
aquarius but
the young people the the people who are
fired up they have and they realize the
problems are not just going to be fixed
by having some conciliation with
transgenderism we've got to rip this
stuff out root and branch right now go
to ziprecruiter.com
knowles hiring is challenging especially
right now when you've got so much on
your plate luckily there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place where growing businesses
connect with qualified candidates that
place is ziprecruiter.com
knowles ziprecruiter uses its powerful
matching technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
you can easily review those recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply ziprecruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day that's why zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site based on g2 satisfaction ratings as
of january 1st 2022 right now you can
try zip recruiter for free
our listeners can go to zip
recruiter.com knowles that is
ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s just like beyonce zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
horrifying scene from a charlotte
pride parade you know the pride parades
they're family-friendly events they're
really wonderful they deserve our public
funding they need space in public square
because it's all about love love is love
and acceptance and they're really really
great right except we all know that none
of that is true and we have video
evidence of it there's a poor little kid
who was brought up onto a stripper pole
with some half naked i think woman
uh and and he was riding on her bare
midriff and lower parts and she was kind
of shaking on the pole showing this poor
little kid how to strut for all of the
other perverts in the audience
this wasn't even really the craziest
thing at this pride part there's a video
of of all of these
i think i think a number of them are
women just jiggling and they're all
not half naked they're all probably 95
naked take a look
[Music]
we've got to blur out most of this stuff
[Music]
this is what we're being told is family
friendly and it's just
a sex show that's all it all it really
is and that's all really that it has
ever been
i'm reminded of a line from jason
whitlock you know jason whitlock over at
the blaze i loved this line i was on a
show with him one time i wish i had the
clip
we're talking about marriage
and what to do about marriage and jason
whitlock was explaining why redefining
marriage is such a dumb idea and i think
this this advice applies to
the pride parades and all the rest of it
he said you know
not everything is for everyone
when i was a young man i was a little
more promiscuous and my friends and i
would go to strip clubs
i didn't get married
because that wasn't for me because if
you got kind of guys going to strip
clubs you can't simultaneously be the
guy that's getting married not
everything
is for everyone
and that's true
that's such a good point a lot of wisdom
there from jason whitlock
pride parades
are not for children
obviously they're filled with leather
daddies and all sorts of sexually
deviant people performing sexually
deviant acts in public those are
obviously not for kids and if you talk
to any of the people who aren't so
twisted in their head who aren't
completely lost and you said hey do you
think a 10 year old should be at this
thing they would probably admit no it's
probably not really appropriate
but
we cannot in public life we cannot
simply tolerate things this is one of
the
this is one of the weaknesses of of
liberalism the modern kind and the
classical kind one of the weaknesses of
liberalism is that it pretends that the
public square is neutral and we can all
just tolerate everything and it won't
affect our public life and that's not
true
people have noticed that we've gone from
moral of program for the weird sex stuff
to then for about five minutes we
tolerated it and then instantly it
became mandatory celebration it's not
just hey tolerate me hey include me now
it's you have to celebrate me you have
to put the pride flag on your shirt you
need to put the special square on social
media you've got to actively celebrate
it
and
that's that's because that's how
politics works we have in order to have
a republic which republic comes from
race public uh
the stuff we've got in common then we've
got to have those things in common and
we've got to have sacred
[Music]
sacred
things in common we've got to exalt
certain things we've got to cast down
other things we have to have taboos
taboos that are very high taboos are
very low and disgusting and we we have
to
we have to come to some agreement on
that
the pride parades are sick and
disturbing and they should be illegal
everywhere and because there's no way to
have the pride parade on main street and
say that the kids aren't allowed to come
because when you do that then you're
admitting that they're obscene and
perverted and when you admit that then
then
you've undercut your argument for having
them on main street right in the public
square
so we've got there's not going to be
some squishy weak lukewarm middle ground
here okay and when you talk to the young
people i can't i talked to a member of
congress not all that long ago
and i couldn't believe how deluded he
was on this question he said you know
i've always
he's a very good member of congress i
really like the guy but he said you know
i just assume young people are kind of
more libertarian that's what i assume
i don't think that's true the young
people that i talk to are way more
hardcore they have way more moral
clarity and way more courage than
the kind of boomer conservatives who are
largely just about cut my taxes and
leave me alone
because they see it because they realize
the consequences of it and we didn't
have to deal with the immediate
consequences during the age of aquarius
we certainly do now i'm glad you like
that clip now you gotta subscribe
we i appreciate it i'm glad we hit a
million subscribers i wanna hit one
quadrillion ring that bell get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you